SPEAKER: With almost 500
sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see Serverless
on Google Cloud, What's New,
then stay tuned,
because here's a rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Serverless technology
continues to innovate
in the cloud namespace, where
that platform takes away
all the complexity that comes
with handling the lower level
infrastructure so you get
to focus on what matters,
your code.
In this talk, we'll discuss all
the new and exciting changes
since last year.
First, we start
with an announcement
that GCP has updated the base
image for serverless offerings
to Ubuntu 18.4,
which gives access
to a broader set of
system libraries,
and also enables some new
capabilities for the product I
write documentation for, App
Engine, who is celebrating
its 10th birthday this year.
Originally shipped in 2008
with support for only Python,
this year, App Engine rolls out
its second generation runtimes,
giving you access to Node.js
8, Python 3.7, and PHP 7.2.
And while App Engine is
celebrating its longevity,
Google Cloud Functions is
celebrating its first year
with a whole set
of announcements.
First, Cloud Functions is now
available for all developers,
making it production ready
and even provides an SLA.
Along with that is
support for more regions,
scaling controls so you
can put an upper limit
on the number of
instances of a function,
and languages, including Node
11 and Python 3.7, both of which
contain common features
like logs, exceptions,
error reporting, and alerts,
all through Stackdriver.
Another great new GCF feature
is environment variables,
specific key value pairs that
are bound to a single function
but don't exist inside
your source code
you set them at deploy
time and they'll
be injected as literal
environment variables
at execution time.
Continuing with the
updates, GCF now
has CloudSQL direct
connection support, as well as
access and IAM support through
VPC interconnect to a network.
Control access to
function invocation
using IAM on the invocation.
You can assign the role of
invoker to a particular user,
allowing you to define who
can kick off which functions.
Great for a function
to function use cases.
Now, something I'm
really excited about
is the availability of a
new tool, Cloud Scheduling,
which allows you to schedule
HTTP Pub/Sub tasks down
to one minute intervals
in both GCF over HTTPS
and invoke App Engine
on relative URL.
You can start setting
up timers for events we
want to happen, like Cron jobs.
For more information
on all these updates,
including a few live
demos of the technology
and a top secret
product release,
check out the full video link
in the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Google Cloud Platform
YouTube channel for more
great Next Rewind content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]